okay thank you and and thank you for
having me out to give the give the talk
so I'm gonna present some joint work
with graduated with Christian Fong but
really this this work begins I think
exactly where where Duncan wants us to
begin with a basic core problem and I
think it's a basic core problem that
political scientists think about a lot
and what we're gonna think about to
drill it down to its most basic element
is how do people things elements folks
out there the world respond to texts or
speeches that are given and just give
you a sense about how general this
problem might be consider some
contemporary things that are happening
in the world for example in the United
States we have a long and persistent
concern with how the public's going to
respond to two demagogues to populist
people who are making appeals that I
have perhaps a little little to do with
what government could actually do this
is actually a certain kind of appeal
that's being a certain concern that's
true across the world the sort of demo
of demagogues and why they're so
appealing to the public is a big and
persistent concern but within government
we also might be interested in well as
well as how elected officials can
persuade the public to enact reforms
that could perhaps be in the public's
best interest or worse yet how elected
officials could pander to the public and
make certain kinds of appeals that dupe
the public into adopting a policy that
on its face seems great but at the end
of the day results in everybody having
to pay a large amount of money for some
gold star plan they didn't want anyways
we also in a campaign season will hear
people breathlessly commenting to us on
the radio and on television about the
sort of concerns about televised ads and
how televised ads are making the the
public much more polarized and how
they're these televised ads are
appealing to the public and really
undermining which would otherwise be a
very sober discussion about what's going
on in in this campaign okay and in my
own work I thought a lot about how text
might relate to how people respond so
here we see Richard Shelby he's a
Republican senator from Alabama he's
breaking ground at the Shelby hall for
engineering computer science at the
University of Alabama it is not so named
because Richard Shelby happens to
a rich man who has donated lots of money
to the state system but rather because
Richard Shelby has perhaps been so
successful at steering money to the
state of Alabama and indeed in extended
projects with Sean Westwood and Solomon
messing we examine exactly this sort of
dynamic how is it that the public learns
about things that their members of
Congress do and in this case how is it
that the public learns about how members
of Congress direct money back to the
district and what we find by analyzing a
really large collection of text that we
gathered from members of Congress is
that politicians create what we call an
impression of influence it isn't as if
politicians only talk about the things
that they've directly secured to their
district and it isn't as if most of
government spending happens through
earmarks which we used to hear a lot
about about in fact will be fined by
analyzing this large collection of
politicians statements is that
politicians tend to claim credit for
relatively small grants the modal dollar
amount claimed for by a member of
Congress is something on the order of a
hundred thousand dollars and that
members of Congress regularly claim
credit for things they had little
influence securing in fact the single
thing that's most discussed in a credit
claiming press release members of
Congress are making the case they
deserve money for their district is
about Fire Department grants so these
are small grants allocated to a small
town it's about fifteen thousand dollars
on order of that amount that members of
Congress claim credit for so having then
studied in depth what members of
Congress claim credit for we also wanted
to get an impression also wanted to
better understand how voters react to
these credit claims so what we did is we
did many what would look like a
traditional experiments we went out
we've studied a lot of these statements
we can now go down we can manipulate
facets of these texts we could put that
in front of people on a variety of
context including in survey experiments
we developed the facebook application to
manipulate the content there and
actually delivered some treatments over
email and what we found is that people
tended to make an inference about these
about what their member of Congress was
doing based on the type of thing the
member of Congress was securing or the
action that was reported rather than the
amount of money secured so for example
in one experiment we show
that voters are much more responsive to
the number of actions that their member
of Congress reports rather than the
amount of money that's secured even
though the amount of money that we were
comparing in that condition was
something on the order of a hundred
times more than the action so voters
were very responsive to actions not
money and voters are also much more
responsive to the type of grant rather
than the amount of money that the member
of Congress secured and so this would
suggest perhaps if we were sitting here
and we were thinking okay we're going to
be problem oriented the problem that we
want to understand is accountability and
what we think that people want is to get
more money to their district this
perhaps then we have a natural solution
here we should intervene and we should
tell people about this particular system
one of the interesting things I think
that happens when we take a step back
and we identify a pattern like this and
think through what are the implications
of this pattern is that that might be
exactly the wrong conclusion so what we
find here is that this system is set up
in a way that rewards members of
Congress for securing things like
competitive grants grants that are
allocated not by political discretion
but rather by a sort of team of experts
who assess the viability of certain
kinds of projects well you might be
concerned with with any competitive
grant process is that it's not very
politically robust if you're a member of
Congress and you want to cut something
cut funding you're not going to do the
thing that allows you to direct money to
your district perhaps you would cut the
thing that you have very little control
over so it would be fragile except in
the instance where this political
institution creates opportunities for
members of Congress to claim credit for
the spending and that's exactly what we
show happens members of Congress are
able to claim credit for spending that
comes out of these competitive programs
that makes these competitive programs
politically robust and perhaps explains
why they're able to persist indeed we
show that some floor votes that members
of Congress take are related to their
regular use of these sorts of Grants and
so here we have perhaps some notion that
were studying accountability and we have
a particular workflow as well that seems
like it would be a useful workflow we're
going to study the text first and then
we're going to look based on the things
we identify in the text will make some
manipulations in the tax interview
response okay but this also suggests
then that as the researcher we're
putting a lot of priority on our own
intuition at the
stage right here what we're saying is
that we're able through whatever tools
we might be able to use whatever fancy
statistical tools we can use that we as
the researcher can identify the facets
of the texts that were most interested
in and then manipulate those and perhaps
we think that we could bake into the
research process some discovery and
that's what I'm going to show you an
example of today using the running
example of candidate biographies this is
yet another problem that perhaps is
persistent in this particular election
but also came up a lot in the 2008-2012
campaigns there's going to be features
of who the candidate is whether it's
their gender their race or perhaps their
background for example serving in the
military like John McCain is here that
could lead voters to be more likely to
vote for that particular candidate and
so the question we might be interested
in what are the features of candidates
that lead voters to like or dislike that
candidate more and then how could we
think about some engineering to think
about pointing out these biases that
voters might have or the implication
these biases might have for whatever
political system are interested in so
across these examples then what we're
interested in is the causal effect of
subtext when it performs the
manipulation in a text and we want to
assess how that manipulation affects
some reaction later on what I'm going to
suggest today is that we're going to be
able to think about discovering the
causal effective text in particular
discovering the things that we might
want to manipulate and then the effects
of those manipulations and so I'm going
to make a distinction that's I think
common across many other types of
statistical procedures so we have what I
think would traditionally be
confirmatory experiments we have some
manipulation that we want to do we want
to confirm that some manipulation has
some effect and I'm going to contrast
that today with some exploratory
experiments or experiments that are
explicitly designed to discover some
feature and then what we're going to try
to do in that same setup is to credibly
estimate the effect knowing about the
potentially bad incentives from things
like P hacking and exploration normally
associated with experiments all right so
what's the target then the target in
this in this setup and I'm going to talk
to you about today is going to be both
discovering treatments discovering
interventions discovering feature
of the text and then credibly estimating
their effect to do this we're going to
have a two-part two sets of tools the
first tool is going to be an
experimental design it's going to look a
little odd in fact it's going to violate
intuitions or rules that you have in
your head about how you can run an
experiment and then I'm also going to
talk to you about a statistical method
that enables us to discover these
features in particular what I'm going to
show is a research design that would
assign every participant in your study
their own distinct text right so there's
going to no overlap on the extend the
intervention okay so everybody's going
to get their own distinct text and then
based on that we're going to infer some
latent treatments and what we're going
to be able to show is that even though
we're just randomizing the text we're
actually going to be able to identify
those latent treatments of course under
a set of conditions and then we're going
to use a statistical method based on
this research design that's going to
enable us to infer the underlying
treatments and then estimate their
effect and we're going to do this
credibly we're not going to subject
ourselves to things like pee hacking our
exploration as long as you follow our
procedure we can make no guarantees of
what nefarious researchers do after they
get the tool though okay in the again
the running example is going to be about
a response to congressional biographies
and what I'm going to show you is that
even though we have what I think is a
fairly counterintuitive setup we're
going to retrieve what I would take to
be some intuitive features of these
biographies what I'll show you is that
people don't like lawyers okay so that's
maybe some good confirmation and that
there's a bonus from serving in the
military people also liked education all
right so how might we do this say we're
interested again in assessing the
features of Canada biographies that lead
voters to like or dislike candidates
more so here's an example of a candidate
biography that actually appears on a
dataset this is from Wikipedia we
grabbed all of the Congressional
biographies off of Wikipedia and so this
particular person one's got to drive the
wienermobile it's quite distinctive in
fact its current Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan his congressional biography it
looks something like this okay so what
might we do we might look at this and
say okay I think from this I can figure
out what makes Paul Ryan ticker not tick
and what makes voters like him or not
so the first thing we might do is we
might include some explicit manipulation
and the indeed this is exactly the kind
of a nip y elation we would do before so
in his current biography there's claims
that he read Hayek in von Mises and
Friedman when he was in college so we
could replace that and suppose you went
to Berkeley and he could read Marx and
zin and Chomsky okay and so this is fine
and you can identify the effect of
making the sort of intervention but it
supposes you know the treatments
beforehand you know exactly what you
want to manipulate beforehand and again
that's fine but that's exactly the
problem trying to avoid so here's
another set up what we could suppose is
that instead of we're going to bury
these blocks I'm going to decompose
these speeches into a big document term
matrix I'll make some sort of assumption
about being able to suppose we just have
a bag of words here or maybe something
like pairs of words and I'll just think
about the effect of a particular word
being there or not so for example I
might suppose what happens if we don't
include economics there and we could
just delete it here and we just have
majored in political science rather than
economics and political science but then
there's another problem it's unclear at
least to me what it means to vary that
that single word what does it mean to
drop this single word here perhaps this
is a case where can make a little bit of
sense because of economics but in other
instances it becomes less clear because
when we think about language treatments
usually think about a bundle of words
some sort of theme being there or not
all right so you may think also that
this is perhaps a known problem we could
solve this using some tool like
supervised lda we could have some
response which would be the thing that
we get from our experiment participants
and then we could look at the topics
that come out of that and so we might
get topics that looks something like
this with education and family and
occupation but there's a problem with
models like lda and that problem is that
the proportions that come out of this
sort of model they're going to live in
the simplex of course their proportions
which means that we can't estimate the
marginal effect of any one component the
only treatments that will be there are
the entire vector of treatments and so
we're often interested in these settings
of knowing if I isolated this one
component and averaging over all the
other conditions what's that effect and
you're unable to do that here and so we
could do something unsupervised this and
sort of other latent factor approach
principal component analysis or factor
analysis or some nonparametric version
of these but any one of these
unsupervised methods are going to fail
to take into account the response and
the result will be that we're not going
to be able to uncover a treatment that's
going to be related to the response when
I could be able to gauging that
prediction so what we're going to try to
do then is we're going to try to have a
setup that's allow us to automatically
discover treatments building on insights
from the machine learning literature and
then obtain marginal component specific
effects all right so how are we going to
do this so here's our setup and then
we're going to show you that these
theoretically that this should work and
that'll give you the example so what
we're going to do is we're going to have
a collection of texts and we'll take
these texts and we're going to randomly
assign them to individuals right and in
particular at the moment just in your
head think that every individual is
going to get their own congressional
biography we know overlap on the
biography obtained by the individuals
will then obtain some sort of response
from those individuals here will suppose
that we just ask folks on a scale of 0
to 100 how much do you like this
candidate so suppose you're some sort of
political party and you're just trying
to assess the viability of candidates
it's not crazy to think you might do
this to figure out what's the sort of
background or perhaps the optimal
background that would be best then given
these texts and responses we're going to
divide our observations into a training
and a test set
in the training set we're going to apply
a method that we call the supervised
indian buffet process because we take
the indian buffet process which is an
existing statistical procedure and we
add a supervision component to it and
this is going to allow us to infer the
latent treatments that are present in
the text and in order to come up with a
final model that we like the one that's
going to help us to infer the late
treatments we use the nonparametric
ciseaux ciated with the indian buffet
process along with measures of
quantitative fit and there's going to be
some qualitative model selection here
we're going to engage in full-on
exploration at this stage because we're
going to have it completely distinct
from the eff estimation stage once we
have a model that we like we're going to
pick it up and in the test set we're
going to use this model to infer the
latent treatments without taking to
account the responses to make sure that
we're not engaging any sort of double
counting and then we're going to
estimate the effects of the discovered
treatments with a regression where we
also include a bootstrapping stage to
ensure that we're including both
estimation uncertainty and uncertainty
that comes from our particular sample
size all right so to give a sense for
why this might work there's going to be
two things we need to know both sort of
framework for seeing that that this is
like not just completely insane and then
a method for discovering the treatments
so what's our framework so we're going
to suppose we have these collection of
texts we're going to pre-process them
preprocess of them like often happens in
the texas data literature so we're going
to toss out word order for example and
what we're left with is a document term
matrix and then we'll standardized that
and we're going to suppose is that for
each observation that the response
depends upon the particular vector of
text that's received all right and what
we're also going to suppose that there's
some function G that's going to map from
those texts into a lower dimensional
space and so we can think about these as
our treatments if you're ever running an
experiment where you're manipulating
texts like a survey experiment you are
imposing this function yourself
basically right you're saying that
there's these there's like much bigger
set of texts I'm imposing this
particular set of things and I'm going
to make an assumption about the
particular treatments that are present
and then we'll suppose that there's the
other related
potential outcome and that's going to be
individualized response to this
treatment will call that why I TJ
alright so we need to make four
assumptions in order for this to work so
here are those four assumptions the
first is we're going to make a fairly
standard no spillover assumption we're
going to suppose that everyone's
treatment status only depends on their
own treatment status the second
assumption is a perhaps a bit more
controversial we're going to suppose
that when we make this distillation when
we take our big vector of text and we
drill it down or map it down to this
latent feature latent treatments that
that captures the all the way in which
the text would affect the response okay
you can imagine that's violated if our
latent if our mapping fails to take into
account some features the third
component were going to suppose that
we've randomly assigned our tax and the
fourth motivates our giving everyone
their own treatment the fourth says that
there's a nonzero probability of all the
treatments of the latent treatments okay
so if we have these four things we can
think about our key quantity of interest
which is the effect of any one component
of this vector being turned on minus
sorry the average response when it's
turned on minus the average response
one's turned off or the effect of this
one component and what we can show is
that even though we're just randomizing
the text and not these latent features
under the set of assumptions we're able
to identify the effect of these latent
features by randomizing those texts so
this research design is going to enable
us to identify these features even
though we're not explicitly randomizing
that this gives us reason to believe
that we can discover some useful useful
interventions with this sort of setup
okay so then the question is given this
design how are we going to actually do
this and to do it we're going to fit a
model that's going to enable us to learn
both the latent features and then how
those latent features predict both the
response and the text so our ideas that
we're going to suppose that treatment
assignments for each document and for
each category are going to come from a
Bernoulli distribution and then
conditional on those treatment
assignments we're going to suppose that
there's some set of latent features that
map into documents and then we're going
to suppose those same treatment
assignments also explain an individual
response so we're going to fit this big
model using our both the responses to
the intervention and and the matrix the
documenter matrix okay so we're going to
take this procedure when you use about
Canada biographies what does that look
like so retiring Senator Barbara
Mikulski you might be worried that if we
delivered exactly her biography to
someone they would know both the text
about what was in the biography and
perhaps they know something about her
and they have some strong affinity for
say Democratic senators from Maryland
and so what we did is we scrambled the
names into using a plausible scrambling
rule which meant that we had to be
relatively intelligent about it not
scramble names across say ethnic groups
and then we delivered a biography that
looked something like this where we say
Schumacher was was born in this town
your parents so it's exactly like
Wikipedia other than this name scramble
and our idea was that for every
respondent in our survey we're going to
ask them to evaluate three congressional
biographies so the procedure is they're
going to observe some text we're going
to elicit their response on a feeling
thermometer and then we're going to
divide these responses into the training
and test set we do the training fire
model on the training set and then on
the test set will use it to infer the
effects using our procedure we end up
selecting 10 total treatments and here
are just some examples of what those
treatments look like so the first
treatment here is one about education
and then we see some about say
partisanship service in the military not
surprising given that these are
congressional biographies over the 20th
century and a lot of people were serving
in World War two and then a pretty clear
Law School biography we can also then
estimate their effect using our
procedure and so doing this again this
is a bootstrap that includes lots of
different kinds of uncertainty what do
we see so we see for treatment three for
example that people like education they
also seem to like military service these
have positive responses but then there's
a negative response to any having any
sort of partisan background and any
background that has to do with law
school
so this is I think intuitive people
don't like politicians and people don't
like lawyers but it's perhaps less
intuitive because the bulk of people who
are in Congress have previous electoral
experience and are in fact lawyers and
so whatever bonus or whatever deficit
they experience from being evaluated in
this way it must be compensated for in
some other way okay so what does this
procedure do this procedure gives us
something that's like an unsupervised
conjoint for discovering the effective
text on responses so it enables us to
discover things like discover treatments
and then get valid estimates of their
effects there's lots of next steps in
this procedure in lots of ways it could
be applied more generally so we haven't
begun to think about really what like a
power analysis would look like in this
sort of setting but it's of obvious
importance there's tons of ways to think
about adding other latent features and
to blend the sort of unsupervised
approach with a supervised approach but
when we think about the applications of
exactly the sort of procedure we could
think about this addressing many many
problems that persist in government and
even outside a government things like
marketing business public health so we
might be interested in designing the
optimal text treatment and this
procedure given us a way to begin
exploring that space perhaps a bit more
completely than we would otherwise so
you can imagine running this procedure
and selecting out the features that have
the biggest response and recombining
those messages in some ways we could
also think about applying this sort of
procedure to other complex treatments so
for example images are often used in the
social sciences as a way to elicit a
response and yet we often very one small
feature of those images when there could
be many many other things going on
exactly this same procedure can be used
for images or videos or if your
political scientist you might be
interested in how legislators voting
record affects the support they receive
an election and also in observational
settings all in service of trying to
better understand how speech can affect
responses thank you